golden state with another stop trying to
close out this third quarter better than
they did in game one
curry
cooking
a colossal three
oh but look on the screen poor otto
porter with a tice is dropping
you cannot guard him like that you have
to be up if you're tight
and the answer is look i'm in position
coach look at my stance that's not gonna
work you might as well be in the paint
you must be on the bench with me
golden state has a lot of time pool with
the ball
launches
oh
money
[Music]
[Applause]
flat out get it done
recognizing the clock dwindling down
knocks down the long ball good
old-fashioned game of
pool
jalen brown goes down the other way
timeout golden state
warriors club napping on that play
turnover and then you're discussing it
mistake made by the warriors outstanding
pass from al office to jaylen brown
[Applause]
[Music]
curry long three pointer it's good and
the foul
steph curry with a chance for a
four-point play we'll pick up the foul
his second
that's a flagrant foul
by the way they do it but now he's back
[Applause]
curry grant williams on him
hurry makes his move gets in the paint
throws it up blocked by williams his
fourth projection of the game
stellar job
of giving energy and effort
how about the limp and
versatility absolute brown all over
spin move lost it momentarily
gets it back leia blocked by brown
rejected out of bounds
does not give up on the play stays
connected to the body of klay thompson